REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS SAY THIS
IS ALL BIDEN'S FAULT, BUT ARE
THEY REALLY?
JOHN AVLON WITH THE REALITY
CHECK.
>> YESTERDAY, PAUL GOSAR BECAME
THE 24th CONGRESSMAN IN HISTORY
TO BE CENSURED.
THE VOTE CAME DOWN TO WHETHER
YOU THINK IT'S OKAY TO THREATEN
TO KILL YOUR COLLEAGUES.
WHICH REALLY SHOULDN'T BE A
TOUGH CALL AT ALL, RIGHT?
ESPECIALLY AFTER JANUARY 6th.
BUT OF COURSE MOST REPUBLICANS
DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO DEAL WITH
THIS.
ALL BUT TWO VOTED AGAINST HIM,
DEFLECTING WITH A FLURRY OF
CAMPAIGN STYLE TALKING POINTS
LIKE THIS --
>> I VOLUNTARILY TOOK THE
CARTOON DOWN, NOT BECAUSE IT WAS
ITSELF A THREAT, BUT BECAUSE
SOME THOUGHT IT WAS.
IF I MUST JOIN ALEXANDER
HAMILTON, THE FIRST PERSON
ATTEMPTED TO BE CENSURED BY THIS
HOUSE, SO BE IT.
UNDER THE PELOSI PRESIDENT, ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT I HAVE
MENTIONED EARLIER WILL NEED THE
APPROVAL OF A MAJORITY TO KEEP
THOSE POSITIONS IN THE FUTURE.
>> TALKING POINTS THAT REALLY
JUMPED OUT AT ME WERE ABOUT GAS
PRICES, AND INFLATION AND THEY
WERE HIT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
HERE'S THE QUESTION.
REPUBLICANS BLAMING BIDEN FOR
GAS PRICES, INFLATION, ARE REAL
CONCERNS.
THEY EAT INTO REAL WAGES.
CREATING THE FEELING THAT THE
ECONOMY IS IN TROUBLE EVEN WHEN
MOST INDICATORS POINT TO A
ROBUST RECOVERY.
BUT IS IT TRUE THAT BIDEN'S
POLICIES ARE TO BLAME, OR
PRESIDENT ASKED THE FTC IS THERE
SOMETHING MORE SINISTER AT WORK?
WELL, THE REALITY IS NEITHER
SIDE IS GOING TO BE TOTALLY
SATISFIED WITH THE ANSWERS.
LET'S TACKLE GAS PRICES FIRST.
THEY'RE AT SEVEN-YEAR HIGHS.
THE PRICE OF OIL IS
SKYROCKETING.
OIL COMPANIES ARE NO RUSH TO
SOLVE BIDEN'S GAS PRICE PROBLEM.
AFTER THE MASSIVE CRASH DURING
COVID, OIL COMPANIES ARE TAKING
IN RECORD PROFITS TO OFFSET THE
LOSSES.
EVEN THOUGH OIL PRICES HAVE
SURGED MORE THAN 65%, OIL
PRODUCTION IS ABOUT 14% LESS
THAN BEFORE COVID.
LOOKING AFTER THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS, AS WALL STREET
APPLAUDS AFTER AFTER A DISMAL
DECADE.
LIKEWISE, THE OPEC CARTEL, WHICH
COULD LOWER PRICES BY INCREASING
SUPPLY, IS REAPING PROFITS AT
THE EXPENSE OF PEOPLE AT THE
PUMP WORLDWIDE.
OPEC AND BIG OIL WOULD RATHER
HAVE REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE.
FOR REASONS RANGING FROM LESS
EMPHASIS ON HUMAN RIGHTS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE DENIAL.
BUT PROFITEERING IS GUIDING
THEIR DECISIONS MORE THAN
PARTISAN POLITICS.
AND WHILE GAS PRICES ARE OFF TO
A POLITICAL ISSUE, THERE IS VERY
LITTLE PRESIDENTS CAN DO TO LOW
THERM ON THEIR OW.
IF YOU TAKE A BIG STEP BACK,
YOU'LL SEE THIS IS A GLOBAL
ISSUE.
IT IS THE RESULT OF RELATIVELY
RAPID RECOVERY FROM COVID
LOCKDOWNS AND THE SPIKE IN
DEMAND FOR OIL AS THE WORLD GETS
MOVING AGAIN.
THAT'S THE CASE FOR INFLATION AS
WELL.
BUT GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN WOES ARE
JUST THAT, GLOBAL.
AND WHILE THERE ARE SOME SIGNS
OF IMPROVEMENT, THIS ISN'T
TURNKEY.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SEEING
INFLATION AROUND THE WORLD.
CHINA'S INDUSTRIAL PRODUCER
PRICE INDEX JUMPED 13% LAST
MONTH.
IN THE UK, INFLATION AT A
TEN-YEAR HIGH.
GERMANY, 28-YEAR HIGH.
FOOD PRICES ARE UP 30% ACCORDING
TO THE U.N.
SO THIS ISN'T JUST A U.S.
PROBLEM AT ALL.
THAT'S WHY REPUBLICAN ATTEMPTS
TO BLAME BIDEN WHILE POLITICALLY
PREDICTABLE ARE NOT ALL THAT
CREDIBLE.
WHILE THE TRILLIONS IN COVID
RELIEF PAYMENTS PASSED UNDER
TRUMP AND BIDEN ADDED TO
INFLATION, THEY HELP FAMILIES
STAY AFLOAT TO SAVE THE ECONOMY
FROM SINKING.
THEY WANTED TO HELP FAMILIES
FROM INFLATION GAS PRICES
AFECTING MOST, THEY TRY TO PASS
THE BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN IT
COULD REDUCE COSTS FOR CHILD
CARE AND ELDER CARE AND
PROVIDING PRE-K AND PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE.
WHEN IT REALLY COMES TO
INFLATION, THE BIGGEST IMPACT
WILL BE BIDEN'S UPCOMING
DECISION ABOUT THE NEXT FED
CHAIR.
THIS IS MOSTLY A QUESTION OF
MONETARY POLICY, AND THAT SAID,
MOST EFFECTIVE INFLATION HAWK
WHO EVER SERVED WAS PAUL VOLCKER
AND HIS DECISION TO RAISE
INTEREST RATES DIDN'T HELP JIMMY
CARTER'S RE-ELECTION PROSPECTS.
BOTTOM LINE, THESE ARE GLOBAL
PROBLEMS.
REFLECTING INTERRELATED WORLDS,
MERGING FROM AN UNPRECEDENTED
PANDEMIC, AND BLAMING BIDEN
ALONE IS ABOUT